Hey youtubers it's Charlie and there is a
bunch of stuff happening with Walking Dead
this weekend including the first trailer for
Season 5 and a behind the scenes look on the
set. Scott Gimple has also given a few details
about what's going on with the story and changes
they're making from the comic and the directions
the characters are going. So this will be
a breakdown of all that with important dates
for the trailer and comic con related stuff.
Hello to any new people, if you're finding
me for the first time I'm doing weekly Walking
Dead videos this summer and I'll be doing
a special giveaway during comic con. So be
sure to subscribe to get everything.
So important stuff first, the Season 5 Trailer.
This weekend AMC is doing a marathon of everything
from season 1 to season 4, at the end of that
on Sunday, they're doing a special Talking
Dead Season 5 Episode where they'll show off
the first footage from Season 5.
There will be a whole bunch of interviews
and behind the scenes stuff. And I'll be doing
a full breakdown video and answering questions.
I've been really lucky in that my friends
at Nerdist also co-produce the show so they
do a really good job of helping me out especially
The new footage will air Sunday July 6th at
9PM Pacific Time on AMC during that Talking
Dead Episode. The first full trailer, like
the first official trailer will air during
Comic Con like it always has.
They'll be posting it online right after they
show it in Hall H. They haven't announced
whether the Walking Dead Panel will be on
Friday or Saturday. But because Marvel and
DC Comics are hogging all of Saturday will
Avengers and new TV Shows, I'm guessing Walking
Dead will show that trailer Friday July 25th.
I will be doing a full breakdown whenever
it posts. AMC doesn't all people to re-post
their trailers, but I'm trying to arrange
for something special. So I'll keep you guys
posted.
AMC is also screening 2 new Walking Dead Documentaries,
the first one is called Inside the Walking
Dead, that's going to be on AMC July 8th at
10PM Eastern Time and the second one is called
Walker University and that will be the week
after that on July 15th also at 10PM Eastern
Time.
So lots of new Walking Dead video to get you
pumped for Comic Con and Season 5. For everyone
asking when it's coming back. Season 4 Premiered
October 13th last year, so expect Season 5
to premiere within a week of that. Typically
they don't air episodes into December, so
doing reverse math I'd say Season 5 Episode
1 will be either the first or second Sunday
in October.
I know a lot of you weren't huge fans of Season
4 after the craziness of Season 3. Rick wasn't
as much fun and there was way less action.
The good thing is Season 5 is a bit of a reversal
of that. Every year they change the show a
lot, and Season 5 is going to be a lot of
ass kicking.
Here's a breakdown of what Scott Gimple has
been saying about it:
The episodes will loosely be inspired by the
comics, because Terminus and the Gareth Villain
is somewhat of an amalgam of the Chris character,
the Leader of The Hunters and because it's
largely implied by people bones right here
that the Terminus people are cannibals like
the Hunters. I'm going to suggest you read
or re-read Volume 11 of the comic "Fear The
Hunters" it's basically issues 61 to 66.
If you have read the comics, please use spoiler
tags when talking about the characters and
what happens during those issues.
The episodes will be different, even Kirkman
has told them in the last couple of years
to quote unquote, "Have fun with the comic
stories". And Norman Reedus is huge on the
show, Daryl Dixon is probably the most popular
character on the show next to Andrew Lincoln.
And Daryl's not even in the comics, so anything
he does automatically has to be a change in
the original story.
I think it just makes it a fun game for comic
book readers to try and guess what they'll
include and looking for easter eggs.
In terms of the big stuff happening, Gimple
said there would be some similar twists in
the plot like last year we got the Virus twist,
then the Governor and everyone getting split
up. I think that just means that in the first
couple of episodes we'll meet the new Terminus
characters as well as the non-Terminus Father
Gabriel character played by Seth Gilliam.
The first big wrinkle in the plot at Terminus
will probably be an official reveal of them
eating people. Like that will be a big oh
shit reveal even though the writing was literally
on the wall. And littered all over the ground.
Gimple and Kirkman have been pretty clear
they don't intend to have a single big bad
like the Governor for a while, that was the
twist at the mid season finale last year.
This year I think it's going to be the Survivors
escaping Terminus.
It's totally possible they could keep them
there all season, but regardless of when they
escape, I'm expecting season 6 to turn into
the journey to the Alexandria Safe Zone. They
have a few states to cross. Supposedly Terminus
is in Macon Georgia.
Gimple also teased some possible future crossovers
with Robert Kirman's Spinoff show. When asked
about crossover potential he said not to expect
it, but it was totally possible when the time
came to introduce a new faction like during
All Out War.
If you haven't read the comic, All Out War
is a storyline that takes place in between
issues 115 and 126. Remember how I just said
were around the Hunters in terms of story
progression. That starts at issue 61. So we're
many seasons away from that.
And yes, I do think that eventually the main
show will get to all the big groups and events
in the comics. It might change them a little,
Terminus for instance isn't in the comics.
And neither is the villain Gareth, the pseudo
leader. For all intents and purposes I'm going
to think of him as being the show's version
of the leader of the Hunters.
In know AMC said they have a plan for 12 seasons
of Walking Dead. As crazy as that sounds you
have to remember that animated shows like
Family Guy and The Simpsons have made it way
past that number. So they could wait for a
couple more seasons before doing Hilltop or
a lot of the Negan story or All Out War. And
that All Out War storyline isn't the end of
the comic.
The next story after that is called A New
Beginning. Robert Kirkman has been very open
about the fact he's going to keep making new
Walking Dead comics until people stop buying
them. So as long as he keeps writing comics,
they'll always have stories they can tell.
The Spinoff is supposed to be something not
from his comics, something inside that universe,
but with characters we've never met before.
I'm hoping they tease a little about that
at Comic Con. But I don't expect to see any
teaser footage for it 2015.
So let me know if you're planning on watching
the Walking Dead marathon this weekend and
if you have a favorite season. I think right
now my favorite is still Season 3, just because
they kept escalating things till the upgraded
ak47 came out at the end.
Like I said, I'll be doing a couple special
walking dead videos on Sunday be sure to subscribe
to get them. I'll still be doing Game of Thrones
too, so don't worry. It's just that there's
that special Walking Dead Season 5 stuff
going on.
I just posted a big video about the new characters
we're going to see, you can click here to
get that. And click here for my top 10 picks
for Negan.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!